TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JEFFREY EPSTEIN DIED SOME
WEEKS AGO, MONTHS AGO AT
THIS POINT.
BUT BASIC QUESTIONS REMAIN
UNANSWERED.
AMONG THEM, WHY DO POWERFUL
PEOPLE APPEAR TO BE COVERING
UP FOR HIM, STILL?
THERE'S A NEW DEVELOPMENT IN
THE JEFFREY EPSTEIN STORY
TONIGHT WE WILL BRING NEW
JUST A MINUTE.
WORTH STICKING AROUND FOR.
FIRST TONIGHT FORMER NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG APPEARS TO BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
NOW, IN THE PLUS COLUMN,
BLOOMBERG IS ONE OF THE
RICHEST PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
MORE THAN $10 MILLION.
MORE MONEY THAN HE COULD
EVER SPEND.
HE IS ALSO HIGHLY POPULAR ON
THE SET OF THE NBC MORNING
SHOW AND ABSOLUTELY BELOVED
ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS.
AGAIN, THAT'S THE UPSIDE TO
THE CANDIDACY.
ON THE OTHER HAND BLOOMBERG
IS NOT EXACTLY THE MAN THAT
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS
PICTURE WHEN THEY DREAM
ABOUT THEIR IDEAL CANDIDATE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY PROMINENT
DEMOCRATS REACTED TO THE
NEWS TODAY THIS WAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW, DO YOU
THINK
JOINK
JOHNK
JOHN DO YOUTHINK THE COUNTRY WAN
JOHN DO YOUTHINK THE COUNTRY WAS
ANOTHER NEW YORK BILLIONAIRE
AFTER DONALD TRUMP?
WE USUALLY ELECT THE
OPPOSITE.
>> AFFECTION THERE IS FOR
JOE BIDEN.
MIKE BLOOMBERG, WHATEVER
GOOD THINGS YOU CAN SAY
ABOUT HIM HE JUST DOESN'T
HAVE.
>> IT FEELS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A HAIL MARY FOR A
CERTAIN CLASS OF FOLKS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE MORE
GENUINE IF HE WOULD ACTUALLY
RUN AS A REPUBLICAN GIVEN
HIS RECORD.
>> I DON'T SEE ANY ROOM
HERE.
IS HE A RELATIVELY
IDEOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL
BILLIONAIRE AND THERE ARE
ZERO PEOPLE CLAM NORRING FOR
THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> MIKE BLOOMBERG IS ALSO
ANOTHER WHITE ENTERING THE
RACE AS WELL.
MANY ASKING IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED AT
THIS POINT.
>> Tucker: OH, HE IS A WHITE
MAN SAYS THE CNN ANCHOR.
MANY PEOPLE ASKING IF WE
NEED THAT RIGHT NOW.
WELL, YOU CAN MOCK AND
DISMISS THAT BUT FOR A PARTY
INCREASINGLY CONTROLLED LIKE
RACIAL COME MISS SARS LIKE
THE ONE YOU JUST SAW BRIANNA
GOLDRIGGER BLOOMBERG IS A
TOUGH SALE.
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE IS NOT
CLAMORING FOR THEIR OWN
ELDERLY BILLIONAIRE
CANDIDATE AND THAT'S TRUE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
OBSERVED, WALL STREET
LIBERALS AND THERE ARE MANY
OF THOSE ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT
ELIZABETH WARREN EITHER.
THAT, WHEN YOU TAKE THREE
STEPS BACK IS THE REAL STORY
HERE.
YOU ARE NOT WATCHING A
UNITED CONFIDENT POLITICAL
PARTY.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
WHEN A PARTY DECLARES WAR ON
ITSELF.
THE CORE PROBLEM IS THERE IS
A MASSIVE GAP BETWEEN THE
COMPONENTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
COALITION BETWEEN NANTUCKET
AND THE BRONX BETWEEN
UNIONIZED AUTO WORKERS IN
OHIO AND NONBINARY
TRANSACTIVISTS OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC COALITION HAS
ESSENTIALLY NOTHING IN
COMMON.
SO FORTH FIRST THREE YEARS
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
THAT HASN'T BEEN A PROBLEM.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN SO FOCUSED
ON HATING TRUMP, ORANGE MAN
BAD, BUT SUDDENLY THEY HAVE
TO PICK A CONTENDER.
THEIR OWN NOMINEE.